greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by Fuji Sports calm listen what are you
doing Muay Thai whether you're doing
jujitsu whether you're looking for mats
weather whatever you want to do fuji
sports they've been there since day one
says Nagasaki was Nagasaki Fuji was
[ __ ] there right
Fuji made the first [ __ ] gay me I'm a
fat [ __ ] I've always loved Fuji for that
reason the a4 I'm down on a 5 when I was
in a six they would tug on me pull me do
everything that [ __ ] D was tougher
than debt go with the super ATO I don't
know much about the Seiko I got one but
I don't like how it looks I'm a super
Rado type of dude or start with the
lightweight $96.00 purple geek rock them
with that one go to Fuji Sports calm
right now press ENTER now get 10% off
your first order delivered to your house
whether it's a [ __ ] karate belt to
choke your wife with whatever the [ __ ]
you need Fuji sports calm is their
number two you need supplements right
you lift them weight you try to put the
pieces together you gotta start with
[ __ ] on it right there plain and
simple that new [ __ ] protein shake
they got the Mexican chocolate are you
kidding me Mexican people invented
[ __ ] chocolate Wow give is you know
what they look like these [ __ ]
Mexicans they're huge why they invented
chocolate let me put cheese on top but
they don't give a [ __ ] my point is for
your supplements you gotta go daddy.com
whether it's the alpha brain the shroom
tech the shroom tech immune lee dog
takes room tech immune thats why he's
got bronchitis and he can't smoke dope
me i snort that [ __ ] you understand me
you got on a plane with a bunch of
[ __ ] foreigners everybody's coming
from a different destination somebody's
got something and I'm saying somebody's
got a fungi to a month these [ __ ]
it might be you shut the [ __ ] up anyway
go to hotter calm right now and press in
Church back 10% off delivery right to
the crib yeah I'm saying take that
[ __ ] meal eat it's a [ __ ] beautiful
day to be alive
the birds are out the sun's out it's
like 90 degrees here in California plus
my main man my jujitsu mentor [ __ ] if
you remember the show kung fool from the
old series in the 70s this is the
epitome of kungfu only for jujitsu
martial arts and the great Nick Gregory
it's how you doing during my Greek
friend South Africa where I love dearly
what's happened brother
ah man I'm just happy to be here I'm
just enjoying the weather as well it's
so good huh it's so good you look good
man I just wanted to tell you as well
I'm actually not your Greek friend I did
the 23andme tests you know I'm actually
found out i'm oniy i can only be 6%
greek at most and the rest is uh
lebanese and british which blew my mind
don't believe me I reckon no I think I
think the same test I came up Chinese
and [ __ ] African which I knew I got
African and you only Cuban you gotta
have African minions all right yeah
absolutely
so he took the slaves and these [ __ ]
savages started [ __ ] them Cubans were
Indians you know like the Tejano Indians
and [ __ ] like that and then but anyway
um from [ __ ] the fork my Spain
remember that regions cool that's the
most blood I haven't me okay number two
is West African number three was Chinese
number four was American Indian
number five was champion number five was
the dick of death
it's a family number five was Russian
Jew which is dicker that's why cuz
plainly say no more I wish that's all I
was Russian jeweler so I don't know my
wife's sure came back that she was an
American Indian okay and her mother's
American Indian so it's protecting their
explanation was that if you're American
Indian it doesn't trace you back for
five generations something fun oh I
don't know how legit 23andme I'm not dog
animal often but not like I said I
always knew there was African turn in my
wife's my wife's dad did it as well and
it popped up because you know you can
share you can allow them to match you up
with relatives that you didn't know you
had and it popped up saying by our
estimation you have a half-sister that
he didn't know about and it just popped
up so he sent her a message I think he's
gonna connect with her which is pretty
cool so he's got a new sister well
that's good I think it to me are to be
very honest I never really understood
and
when doing this stuff Mike don't why
does it look
why does everyone care what but that
would be cool to climb like a long-lost
relative but like I never really
understood what people wanted me
basically for the health one mm-hmm
they have like a screening of you're
susceptible to okay like what diseases
you could have or what problems you may
have or what areas I did it for that
reason I think they said you're
susceptible to smoking weed right I'm
susceptible to smoking weed and I had a
high you know it was different areas
like I had a high chance of cardio huh
just because of family history like you
have to really look at family history in
a lot of situations you know could it
make you change your lifestyle when you
find these things out oh yeah absolutely
yeah I know I had like that hard cut
I've always you know I started out a
really healthy guy like today I talked
to a kid that we went to karate together
that karate school was blue long before
the Japanese master comes over and your
key has to be ironed and you really buy
into it for a few years and you realize
it's all a [ __ ] stunt that the guys
coming over he's called 10 academies
he's picking up five envelopes and foot
5 G's apiece
he's not even Japanese doesn't even know
[ __ ] karate just you know whatever
yeah it was such a cloud of [ __ ]
smoke so uh I talked to him today no
grab hold me you know we still talk 40
[ __ ] years later so that's cool does
he do jujitsu no not now you don't do
dick now his father dime left me ten
million dollars you goddamn he just
spends money he had a sex slave for
awhile
first when I first reconnected with him
about 2008 no the first time I
reconnected with him was after I did The
Longest Yard uh-huh we spoke on the
phone
cuz he'd always contacted me for years
on December 17th
that's when my father and mother my
mother and his father mother would come
over to the bar
it's a Cuban holiday December 17 in
Saint Lazarus day
so we also went to karate together and
we also went to Bruce Lee movies okay
and we hung out with a lot of guy who
was half [ __ ] there's Mike seriously
uh-huh and he says he still talks to
Mike okay Mike's family owned buildings
in Union City and he always lived in the
basement so Mike's family lived in one
building and Mike lived in the other
building by himself in the basement can
you imagine me that [ __ ] 8 year old
kid 8 years old
sharing a basement with your brother so
we turned into a little martial arts
studio we bought the [ __ ] thing that
you hold it with the canvas on it yeah I
lit up he had poles we wrapped them with
farm we kicked the [ __ ] things so we
didn't always sleep over crazy mike is
no more someone went through a wall or
something no that was Mary odias ass
that was that was a Cuban Chinese kid
that was pirate off-the-charts smart
okay like and like they were like
[ __ ] millionaires smart he lived in
this house up in North Bergen and he was
a colorful kid okay like a fool job I
can fool kid I was a Goju Bush Andrew
karate kid did you guys fight it out
this he was the best
braum every night Sammy when you're 12
11 - the debt we would knock it down and
he had there was like he no kid on the
block
yeah a judo kid uh-huh and we would just
[ __ ] each other
we all made commitments we all went to
Honda Sports okay and we all promised
each other we had to buy them boxing
gloves and we bought the headgear which
in those days was huge you look like a
cat that never got fixed
you ever see when a cat male cat never
gets fixed he lives for a long time I
haven't noticed that I if you ever see a
male cat that hasn't gotten fixed and he
you know if you adopt a cat you fixed
him hmm
but if you don't fix him they get so
much testosterone that their head starts
to grow no [ __ ] and the head gets so
[ __ ] big that it looks like [ __ ]
the Sunnat and crazy
no is this for real it's for real
because my the kid the cats I have their
dad was a pure killer who lived outside
and the people who lived in the building
my wife said he was out dozens he was a
kit and he was crazy
yeah and showed up like hey guys eight
brothers and sisters but then they all
got killed he's the only one that
he had a knack for survival this guy was
just badass so how do we get off [ __ ] I
was just saying about that the helmet
with the kid was this cat part of the
Fight Club I didn't know what happened
so we just had big helmets on him we
bought the shin guards in those days
which are two pieces yeah and you got to
pull them up they were like the shin
guards now and Muay Thai when you strap
on yeah and about nine o'clock at night
we'd all make up some [ __ ] excuse
that we were going to Mac because he's
just he was a smart kid
uh-huh well going over to do homework oh
[ __ ] you
we had our keys already over there we
haven't made the movement over there the
data we put on [ __ ] DS on and just
start [ __ ] blast until 10:30 kicking
each other
uh-huh we do the high end pom techniques
we had the [ __ ] rocks in the backyard
and we'd sprinkle the chin chin juice on
your hands and we do that Bob that we
were gone well we would God this is you
know America was a different from from
68 69 which some people that listen to
those bad guys weren't even born it was
an over flooding of after the Green
Hornet an over flooding of Asian martial
art movies came over here cuz Bruce Lee
was in The Green Hornet used it was in
The Green Hornet he was Canada right
after that like the first martial arts
film I remembers five fingers of death
no no that had to come out in 6970 that
one was about the iron palm tech okay he
would go like that his palm would turn
red and then he'd [ __ ] you up a weird
noise came up that had to be 69 seven
okay and then after that every movie
theater like we were talking about the
movies the other night how in the 70s
and 80s early eighties
every move every town had a movie
theater had a midnight movie and it was
either Pink Floyd Pompeii or whatever
but at the same time they had colorful
festivals and you never seen teenage
boys blues their mind there was
seriously yeah you know two dollars come
here 11:30 and you don't like get that
lose till five and you've seen two
karate move when you're 13 all that
testosterone you come on there you start
throwing punches we've gone into movie
theaters and what you did was you went
in your karate school so I'd go with the
[ __ ] white dragons and Lee would come
with his Taekwondo school and you would
show up there was no jiu-jitsu that
jiu-jitsu wasn't even on the map
you had a drive for judo okay you have a
drive for judo the only thing around was
pure karate peor come fool there was an
Aikido school in Manhattan and one in
New Jersey but that's it you had a
[ __ ] drive for judo judo was in the
village the judo club and there was a
Russian Cuban dude who taught judo on
7th Street and that's where the the judo
guy that we'd always beat up yeah
because the judo guy was great that we
trained with but he could never put his
arms around this we punch him in the
face leg ties but IRA put his hog honest
he was like a brother over would fall
off his world fact I spoke to him
yesterday
I spoke to the judo kid yes yes they
called me and I was swimming with my
wife his name is Martin Perez okay his
father his father was Batista's driver
and Havana Cuba we were kids they shot
his father and this remind me Batista
its East is the guy before Fidel if I
got through oh wow
okay del overthrew when glue was corrupt
my gun surprised you guys didn't brawl
in the movie theater stall they were
fistfights all the [ __ ] time what I
still remember being a kid like being
maybe eight and going to a movie theater
148th Street one at one Saturday
afternoon where there was a colorful
flick and it was black people white
people for reconsideration Italians let
me taste that was twenty four we do like
picturing Gangs of New York
come on Scorsese focus like snow this
was so much because during the week
professor I lived amongst nice white
people but on the weekends my Santeria
godmother lived on 148th Street and that
was in these days this is the wild wild
west of Harlem this was the mouth of
Harlem you know that really Harlem the
mouth of Harlem is 125th Street 118
no but this was a desk though and there
was a movie theater in the middle and I
remember that I fell in love with the
movie called our Latin thing and I
[ __ ] went to the movies every day
everything I wanted to see that movie
because they played it every day what
was it about it was about a Spanish
lobster band that I still listen to the
time in fact I have the movie album in
there but I still remember going there
on a Saturday like the two o'clock movie
would be like [ __ ] a kung fu movie oh
my god there will be people ubc popcorn
flying for me when I was growing up like
the ninja crazy just hit you know like
that it was the eighth of the mid 80s of
yes yes yes and I remember like every
year between the ages of maybe like 9
and 12 I can have this slumber party for
my birthday right like and my parents
would just stay upstairs and the
downstairs part of the house they'd be
like you and your friends can watch
movies and you know hang out and this
new series of movies had just arrived in
South Africa on VHS called American
ninja you remember those with Michael
Dudikoff yes and a similar kind of thing
happened we watched a couple we what we
rented American ninja one and two and
watched them back-to-back and it was the
same at the end of that it was these
like 10 or 12 little little kids who had
just lost their minds I mean like
everything was a ninja weapon and their
dudes like hiding behind the curtains
and guys like jumping oh it was pretty
fun yeah we had the luck of our movie
theater was on 48th Street my mother had
a bar on 29th Street and the movie
theater was on 48th Street so we'd
walked those 20 blocks and just rage you
know we were young kids on the street 8
9 years old just talking about what
dreams we had wait 20 blocks that's not
like it's like a minute was like nothing
oh I was like nothing in that day we do
that walk every day twice twice we do
that walk from my mother's bar because I
think there was a place father had good
Cuban food the thick stuff like the rice
and the beans the sandwiches down the
corner but finish the story that on the
way home and that kung fu theater it
would be late if they had a it was
called Elson
and if you went to see like Enter the
Dragon yeah anything five fingers at
that and a one-armed swordsman or
whatever the [ __ ] was playing you leave
they're all testosterone and you'd be
walking down the boulevard Bergin line
Avenue and on 31st Street maybe there
was a huge fruit market huge I'm talking
the size of this building in another one
okay and in front of it would be all the
boxes of fruit and we would start
beating no stairs we would start kicking
those boxes they would fall into the
street and I see cars driving around the
boxes
we'd have 60 feet of boxes to beat the
[ __ ] and they just fall over then the
cops would come we'd run away like a
little faster yeah that's great
I actually remember that feeling you
know you mean when you're when you're
young before you have cars and you and
your buddies it's like summer vacation
and you just you just walk here on
you're so bored but like you just walk
around looking for something to do but
it's it's you're still having a really
good time you know and the thing for me
I went to Thailand about ten years ago
and there was a bunch of these digital
nomad dudes who I became friends with
you know people just work from their
from their computers and it was kind of
that same feeling as when we were kids
walking around like because we just walk
around the streets of Bangkok but the
cool thing was we weren't like broke
little kids anymore we'd all like made
you know we were adults oh we could
afford to do the real cool stuff and so
it just made me think of that what was
your introduction to martial arts
professor ah judo man my dad was like a
karate guy a good karate guy and there
was no but there was no karate class
where where I lived but the school was
doing judo so uh my best friend it was a
year older than me but he was in the
same grade he said I remember telling my
mom that like he was doing judo and then
I was like I want to do that I want to
do that so my mom said sure you can try
it and no end like it the age of seven
and I did judo and I loved it man just
loved it absolutely love it I was pretty
good at it and so that was at judo yeah
now how old were you seven seven and how
long did you stick with it ah probably
like four or five years and then I got
like distracted and right right that's
what same doesn't happen to me and those
years did you feel the Zen of it
did you experience the Zen of them yeah
yeah we when you were a Taekwondo guy
did you ever experience the Zen of it at
any point or was it something that you
just put your suit on gotten the call we
did that and felt you were forced to do
you didn't see the Zen ago
I liked forms I don't know that sounds
really dorky but that's what I I was it
was good for actually that was the
biggest trophy I ever won I won first
place informed upon a year it's the cut
that's right yeah yeah and I I I really
enjoyed it you practice numbers oh yeah
yeah well many times a day I don't know
if it was every day but I remember when
you were getting ready to the to test
for the new belt however we would had it
we had a living room we push all the
furniture out of the way and do it for
my mom 8,000 times and and just uh yeah
I still kind of number one like you'd
like a right block kick punch it was
just and then you just do it to all four
corners won't close and you can uh okay
look you're supposed to get your moves
really crisp and do it exactly right I
like that I I think I was so young
because I don't think I was even 10 yet
I think I don't remember doing a lot of
sparring but we would do a little bit
and I got I got all the way to red belt
and then I just I was a kid and I got
bored and like once you turn 13 and you
see [ __ ] a little bit of alcohol yeah
14 and then because that was my conflict
my conflict was my karate friends would
buy the book they were a lot of fun no I
know when I look back now I had a lot of
fun with those guys on the weekend is
because we were karate geeks mm-hmm
which meant that we were exposed to New
York City on a Saturday so we would all
lie to our mothers you go in library
Willona library right will over [ __ ]
that we take a bus over to the city we
all save our money you delivered papers
Lee worked with his father at the shoe
store I worked at my mother at the ball
and we go over on Saturdays to a [ __ ]
martial arts supply place that was a
couple floors
ya know what that's like when your
martial arts week yeah you know and I
still remember the time for before cops
at yeah yeah yeah that's how old I am
I still remember the Kabul tonfa was
sold in black belt magazine and and uh
and there was a wooden one or like the
wood would not stick yeah
the new chucks that were octagon they
were octagons like all that share yes I
remember
my dick getting hard and walking into
that building yeah that's the feeling I
that was the Zen part of him I kind of
felt the Zen part of it but [ __ ] and
drinking what my buddies was better so
her hand in the martial arts at the age
of sixteen Erna I just said this is too
much I didn't like I was playing
basketball then you know and I didn't I
had a tank you know once a week I could
make it when I'm late basketball
practice till 6:30 by the time I got
home chained and took another bus I'd
hit the men's class from 8 to 10 you
know they had a men's classes [ __ ] well
it's so weird how do it does that of it
always stayed with me yeah I get it
and then something really weird happened
Mike when I was starting Tom Lee and I
was going through all my divorce [ __ ] I
joined the tank sudo scores about dos
school and I stuck with that for about a
year and the only problem with that is
you could buy your way through the
system you can be a black belt and
[ __ ] a year and a half if you want
and then sell you my gold belt after you
get to be a ho you could sell the for
you if as long as you know the forms you
could test in the test every testing
period which wasn't really good but I
can learn the forms and the three basic
techniques or whatever and then I forgot
about martial arts I became a comic I
move on I came back here
and that same style of soo bahk door was
on the corner and it was too late
reverse I was 300 astonished yes and I
would go and there in the morning class
and stop but it just wasn't working and
then we moved in the cocaine the whole
thing how do you think what do you think
was the biggest fact to them that caused
you to get so out of shape Joey if it
was if you could sit and go down one
thing the out-of-control eating you
didn't okay the other control waiting
the other control eating was I could eat
you know nobley
when I was a kid I was very thin and I
was ashamed so I want to tear and I've
lifted weights that did everything you
could do to get bigger and I started
gaining weight and I stayed at a great
weight till about 28 and then it was
nothing serious it was to 20 to 27
nothing serious I still had big broad
shoulders I still had big [ __ ] hands
you know
Dennett once I got to Seattle once I
became a regular at the store I was
probably 255 mm-hmm and once I became a
regular at the store I just became
unhinged yeah it's just like as you get
a little bit out of shape then you kind
of want you almost like give up right
like that's because then you're like it
exercise becomes harder so you exercise
less and then you get a bit more out of
shape and then you eat more and then
it's just this like vicious circle is
that crazy about how at the age of 30 I
was back in New York City I've gotten
divorced I was broke and I was
exercising like a [ __ ] lunatic I
worked out in a gym for free because
these two kids when we were kids their
house burnt down
they lived over a bodega and my mom
helped them out so when they recognized
me they said what's on your Coco no you
don't pay so I had a gym in Jersey okay
and I signed up for a boxing gym in New
York because they buy a locker and put
clothes in there my notebooks is [ __ ]
now I could run around New York City go
to the boxes you can get a little
workout in for 20 bucks paying a guy to
try hit the mitts a little bit take a
shower put on new outfit write a few
jokes and then [ __ ] going on over
there so I always kept the shape
Colorado I had a bench in my living room
it's once I left Colorado in 95 mm-hmm
and I became in love with comedy I can't
explain what happened I don't know what
if we compare it was three eggs for
breakfast a half a loaf of Wonder Bread
done yeah that's probably did it right
there just the one I'm gonna do eight
slices yeah I today I take a half a
piece of bread and I cut the yolk I
don't need any egg white [ __ ] that [ __ ]
only Danielle and I put only the egg
yolk okay
- bread no butter no nothing before I
would break the yolk and I wouldn't be
done to all the yolk juice was broken if
it took 12 pieces of bread with butter
on a stick 12 pieces of bread with
butter by mr. - tenant to ten and my
wife would cook the whole pack of bacon
to have the Oscar Maya the whole pack of
prime cut the middle KY every morning
every morning before she leaves
so I'd wake up to bacon and my wife in
the South Jack and my wife would have
let's be honest two slices of bacon yeah
and I would eat the rest hmm then I
would smoke some pot a few cigarettes
get my blood pressure really up and I'm
gonna McDonald's you know and get the
morning breakfast well this is after you
had the breakfast that house is that
record requisite well now when I have
laid it had to be before 11 o'clock damn
I could all get the McMuffin with the
potato and a full-size coke
oh and then two hours and I'll go for
Chinese food which is just no bueno hole
and yeah yeah the [ __ ] appetizer with
the thing the spring roll it's the
grease is coming out of it yeah Kevin
rice is six seven points but whatever
was in the food you know the goat meat
and then I would go home and my wife
would have some in the afternoon I would
eat like there's something a piece of
meatloaf and then for dinner I would
just kill it so this is like six meals a
day basic and then and then I go up and
if I was doing coke I would drink
alcohol which soda but even if I wasn't
doing cold
I would drink sixteen soda Jesus you
know just keep going back to the bar
drinking you're thirsty I'm gonna have a
sink of water I never even thought of
water as an option like it was dying I
only drank water when I take it out our
vitamin like you know helpful [ __ ] you
okay [ __ ] water I never drink water
since I was a kid like water you know
something I noticed uh recently I put
this together because I put on a bit of
weight and I'm trying to cut down and I
realized that all the people might in my
life who are thin they all have one
thing in common that's it they all eat
really slowly
they don't really eat anything different
but they just eat really really slowly I
mean notice that's the secret yeah
that's the real secret to eat
laughs push the dish away yeah but it's
not able to do that talk for 10 minutes
yeah can you do that because I tried I
am I've been doing it lately I've been
at a little bit I push the dish away and
talk to my daughter okay
then we talk to talk talk at the table
we talk like a family uh-huh and then
I'll pull the dish back in and eat the
other half fair enough
I got to get into that so I'm a [ __ ]
Savage I eat like a father in prison I
really did I eat like this twenty dudes
and this six cheeseburgers oh yeah so
that's what I eat like I'm very ashamed
of that time period in my life is so
weird because I still remember it being
like February of January and I borrowed
money from Josh wolf because I had an
audition for a pencil commercial mafia
commercial I was gonna be huge Sopranos
were out so everything they were doing
at the time was mafia related in 2000
from 99 to 2003 I booked everything that
was mafia-related I would go out on
three mafia auditions a week but I
booked the Pennzoil commercial everyone
and they similarly we need you back here
Thursday for a callback have a suit I
don't have a suit so I went to the
Hollywood suit outlet and they gave me
three suits three shirts three [ __ ]
socks elves yeah three both with two
allows but just don't smoke a cigarette
next to that suit you know like a
[ __ ] you will light up like a [ __ ]
uh uh terrorism bomb inside blow up into
flames so I bought the three suits see
they tailored them for you mm-hmm
and maybe too much later maybe six weeks
later I had an audition I put the suit
on I went to put the suit on you know
sometimes you put your pants on and he
just took the belly and gave this um
wait guys I was three inches away from
getting them getting the trousers on I
just bought this suit six weeks about
and I'm three inches away but at that
point the sleep apnea had kicked into my
life oh yeah
every dose and you know I found out that
during sleep apnea your body releases
cortisol which I was already starting to
get the ball on my back what does that
mean
when at night when you sleep with your
fat [ __ ] and you can't breathe at night
your body goes into danger mm-hmm and
once that body goes into danger what
does your body release cortisol yeah so
when you sleep and it happens at night
that's why when you see obese people
they have lumps on their backs nosh
that's the collection of the cortisol
cortisol earlier like when I finally
decide to get help
it was when I could feel that I was four
1818 pounds I was falling the karate -
yeah I did The Longest Yard and The
Longest Yard tricked me psychologically
because I said to myself this is gonna
be great cuz now I'm gonna be the fat
guy from now on so what the [ __ ] so let
me just eat more part of them ah yeah
yeah let's enjoy this yeah yeah you know
my favorite thing those days was going
and buying that not the 16 ounce coke
but the 32 months and getting a pint of
New York super fudge chunk and I had a
big glass my wife got me a glass from
somewhere like a milkshake glass and I
would take the whole plate them New York
super fudge chunk empty it in a glass
card and put soda on it and mix it out
cod until the whole soda and the thing
we're done I was headed to death
gee I had the cigarettes add the cocaine
I had the [ __ ] sleeping for night so
four hours a night yeah I was just going
and I was just going and I remember that
half the longest yard while he was shoot
while we were shooting the longest shot
in New Mexico was when they put me on
oxygen therapy at that time when I shot
the long as you're on I was probably
about 380 and that's what I realized I
have to some of my life so they had a
trailer where you could work out and I
would go in there on the set and just do
[ __ ] it but I would never get on the
scale
I didn't want to see the [ __ ] scale I
got I didn't want to see the [ __ ]
scale like I didn't find that I was 4:18
till I went to some [ __ ] place and I
got on that scale it was like some
doctor's office and I was like four
[ __ ] 16 I think I was that's the
truth and I mean that number 400 like
once across that unknown yeah you're
done around you're in local waters of
that year it was something professor
that I can't
my wife was tying my shoelaces she
wasn't married to me yet is this the
same way if you have known yes and say
oh my five now she already loves you
this time my shoelace yeah half the
Longest Yard I said [ __ ] it I play the
fat guy if they're gonna pay me I'll
play the fat guy hmm then I kept doing
it but guess what there was no more fat
rolls so I thought it was acceptable you
know I really thought this is acceptable
behavior you have to me to do this and
I've went across the street to the YMCA
finally one day I treated to YMCA like
it was a gay bar like I wouldn't even
look in like I knew I mean professor
when I tell you it was across the street
I'm not telling it was a wrong the car
wasn't even s60 pace walk from my front
door the YMCA it was a three minute walk
and it's basically a free gym
it's a [ __ ] cherry and I treated it
like it was a place that gave out AIDS
I'm not gonna they're gonna give me aids
in there and then finally I go let me
just go in there see what's up and I
took up a brochure a pamphlet it said uh
coming for a free health evaluation with
a trainer
don't go ahead I [ __ ] signed up but I
made it to the appointment and it God
put me on the treadmill if that [ __ ]
they pulled up 2.5 I think I had to get
off the 30-something said God Sam and
the guy goes listen go quit smoking go
for walks and come back when you lose
dirty paddles he goes there's nothing I
could do feet well and then I went back
there on my own after I would box in the
mornings and then go back there on my
and hit the bag and I would ride the bus
stationary bicycle at that time and that
and I went to Weight Watchers Weight
Watchers the best thing that ever
happened they can really knock me out of
thing yeah D then especially now today
the program is tremendous because it's
all protein tall this fair enough
you know they'd only want you to read
even red meats a little serious like I
had pot roast today and it cost me in
the points then the point is I've never
I'm not familiar with weight what does
your mind you know it works again right
now at this time mmm any piece of fish
shellfish is free you can eat as much as
you want you got six lobster tails
bring them on okay no sauce but just the
meat itself just to meet it so it's five
points for a tablespoon of butter five
points five points okay better play your
cards right how many points do you get a
day forty okay okay yeah sure enough and
so if I eat eggs are free there's many
X's you want sixty five eggs at that
damn okay and chicken breasts for free
this protein like keeps you feeling full
yeah yeah so you can't lose you know
vegetables are free juice is free after
you and I were discussing on the way up
here there's a couple weeks ago way then
I was a pound overweight I know how do I
gain a pound it was because I was going
to the acai place and she explained to
me that eating fruit and blending fruit
is two different stories because of you
so IVA enzymes in your mouth breaking
down and separate the sugars or
something like that so just learning
that it was worth the [ __ ] program
now I know that like they agree you want
to eat three bananas with your eggs
if you eat six scrambled eggs and three
bananas it's [ __ ] free well well you
just ate breakfast for free if you do do
that
they'll put ketchup on your [ __ ]
exits gonna cost you a couple points but
so there's ways to finagle the system
you lose weight yeah and you lose weight
you learn how to eat the right way yeah
you know many people have like I was
referred for that surgery and
what I didn't do it yeah doesn't do
nothing yes it doesn't change your
reading habits hmm
the best thing that ever happened to me
was me walking into a Brazilian
jiu-jitsu school that's cool how I came
upon you the best day of my life I never
had a good day when I was growing up
like maybe I went to fire star
basketball camp maybe you know those
accomplishments of the 16 20 years I was
stuck in a rut so the best
accomplishment I made was getting
married another accomplishment was
sticking with stand-up the biggest
accomplishment was getting off the drug
of drugs and then getting married and
having my daughter the big
accomplishments but for me what changed
my life completely was walking into a
jujitsu studio no that's cool yeah it's
a lot of people have had their lives
turn around completely there's a guy um
I forget his surname I think his first
name is Josh you can find him if you
search for digits you saved my life and
he lost I think you lost him like 50 or
60 pounds in a year and he devoted
himself to GT was like a really unhappy
out of shape and no Drive no zest for
life and he started doing jujitsu and
all those things taking care of it I
think it's cause like you know you're
hanging out with people and your brain
is engaged your body's engaged this is a
very healthy thing to do it what
jiu-jitsu did for me was it showed me
how weak I really was it showed me that
when I was thinking about being in shape
I was completely wrong it showed me that
I was eating wrong it showed me I was
living my life wrong it was a real
wake-up call and I still um but joining
you Jitsu be involved with jiu-jitsu
maybe three months and getting on stage
and bombing I opened up for Rogan
downtown like in the summer in July it
was like a summer gig when which here
was this
now when aiwei to 17th we're 39 to 18 so
this is 213 so this is I joined you
Jitsu in 13 okay but I joined like in
March or something after the baby was
born just that July into the show and so
jiu-jitsu when I walked out of that
jiu-jitsu school after I did a couple
hip escapes I never felt my head feel
that way I never felt my body like I saw
when I was walking out and getting into
the car I said I'm happy I did this
because I know I'm never gonna do this
again but by the time I got in the car I
made the right turn on Burbank Boulevard
was headed back to constant I realized
that I had to come back because this
can't exist in my life these holes in my
game what if something really happens
and I have my daughter and I can't
handle myself this is what I need to do
and I went to that place for a few
months and I didn't really I loved it it
was completely blind I was basically
going to there breathe professor that's
it
if I could [ __ ] a breeze never mind an
armbar I'm gonna mount from [ __ ]
Quasimodo's knuckles I'm just worrying
about breathing and living if I could
come back to my car and live and I would
write like a will so what did you just
do on Monday
you know it's [ __ ] at me professor it
[ __ ] with me that I started pressing
in YouTube and then you came up and it's
cool the first video you spoke about was
breathing and now get on your side
there's something don't stand your back
and bah-bah-bah and that was like first
off if anybody knows anything about me I
don't really like these [ __ ] limey
accents but your accent was [ __ ]
assuming your voice was very soothing I
could tell that you were a patient
professor accretion I could tell that if
I was in your class you would come over
and gonna put your leg so I started
watching all your videos and it really
really really really encouraged me
that's great like I knew that I had a
shot now they weren't keep telling me
those little things I so I realized I
was at the wrong place
that made me automatically realize I was
eternal places I got a writing job which
made me go to Higgins and what's that
writing job and that I couldn't justify
going down a Higgins I like he gonna
stuff it there was nobody in the class
in the daytime mmm half the time I go
down there to talk you know I'm saying
so how Bertels I loved you know I was
with rbirtle for two years loved him
still friend of mine whatever but once I
got this little gig and I started
getting more busy at my schedule change
and like I said before the class started
I read one of Roy beans
he fought John Jacques Machado to the
death didn't know his coach Roy Harris
for Roy Harris yeah his article okay see
it's Lou Harris is article he doesn't
say Diego yeah yeah he's an instructor
he's drying it I tried to get him on the
podcast I think he watched it heard the
curse words me [ __ ] yes he's quite a
religious cut yeah he's like that's what
yeah that's what I heard yeah yeah I
think he so the story with him is uh he
again I don't I can only repeat this
story secondhand but it's my
understanding that he got one of the
great yeah one of the Machado's at
training he was like a purple belt or
something and he got one of them in this
really tricky move called a banana split
cuz we basically twisting the guy's back
and then they kicked him out because
they were pissed off about that cuz it
wasn't like a true GG to move apparently
it was kinda like over almost like an
illegal move and then he went and got
his black belt somewhere else and then
there was color this grudge match
between him and John Jacques and at that
time John Jacques he was winning a lot
of stuff I think in 180 CC and a whole
bunch of other big tournaments when Roy
D Elroy Harris had just got his black
belt and said these guys fought and
jean-jacques won but only by two points
and apparently Roy Harris had him in a
couple of very compromising positions
obviously Jean Jacques managed to escape
and I think that was quite a pretty cool
story that he could get to that level
because Jean Jacques is uh he's no joke
man that guy's no fun it's very clear
like you just use one of the only things
that you ever hear that with like hey I
lost but I only lost by one point like
like and that's like not that it's not
an accomplishment but equal you think
like all only winning is something to be
proud I'll be like no this guy's so good
I only lost by five points doesn't
matter well I mean it depends on mazing
the guy you're fighting is if he's I
mean if you only lost by one point to a
chump
you're still a chump right it's true but
I if you only lose by a couple points to
your guy like Jean Jacques then then you
can hold your head up right now why did
you do to hit me so hard like that why
did it show me all my weaknesses I'll
tell you what else did you two did it
made me a better comedian no I
I'd like to you're on that's true
because boy it wasn't jujitsu as much as
MMA the whole game of MMA I would see
guys in between fights and it's always
the same [ __ ] yeah you know Lisa it's
tough but wait till he goes up against
my right hand so that's all you're
talking about for the rest of your life
is your right hand I don't work on bar
you're not gonna work on a leg kick
you're not gonna work on a [ __ ] judo
throw so right there it opened up my
horizons like look how these guys are
thinking they depend too much on one
thing you can't depend too much on one
thing yeah there's a saying yourself out
you've heard the saying of a
specialization breeds weakness yes yeah
that's it you know with comedy the other
day we have a great conversation here
well Dean don't worry was saying for a
year he forced himself to go on stage
and just improvise you know you got
number time you got nothing to lose
improvise well you can't because that
teaches you a different muscle hmm then
for a year you force yourself to host
even though you don't want to be a
[ __ ] host because hosting teaches you
how to control the tempo of a comedy
show mmm how to control the tempo this
guy sucks you gotta bring that audience
back just because this guy's suck don't
mean you can't let the show go now you
gotta go plan and save that joke but you
already did that joke so Jesus now you
got to do a better joke you gotta go in
between eight and nine people three or
four people so there's so many aspects
to economy
and the same way there's so many aspects
to jujitsu you know the same way there's
so many aspects to life to life it's
like everybody praises Bruce Lee I love
I loved it I loved what he did for me as
I was growing up but if you really think
about it Jeet Kune Do is what we all do
at one point are lies you figure out
what works for you we do a complete set
of [ __ ] things you do them the same
way every day and you ain't equals to a
certain type of success I do the same
[ __ ] every day at the same [ __ ] time
you know that wasn't taught to me that
was that's not who I am
I don't want to do the same [ __ ] every
day at the same time but for me to get
to a level where I want to be at this is
what needs to be done hmm I don't give a
[ __ ] if your [ __ ] hurts I don't give
a [ __ ] of you sucked a thousand big
that's right I don't give a [ __ ] of your
back hurts I don't give a [ __ ] if you
don't feel good this is what needs to be
done on a daily basis and you know and
when the time come when you get that
success or whatever you're looking for
what needs to be done is gonna change
probably as absolutely yeah absolutely
don't listen
getting there is one thing staying there
is a nothing staying at that level in
your money you know I realize now for me
to be a sharp comic on the weekends when
I work I got the other stage a lot more
than what I'm getting on stage recently
a little older you know I'm starting
again to that [ __ ] that page that
time to time to together you know saying
but if it means going to a fourth war
during the week going to flappers you
know just to get an easier spot because
it's closer to my house I have to drive
over the hill to Sunset Boulevard and
put up with all that stuff I'd do that
you know I might as well do that to let
him go I got a local spots tonight I'd
rather do those I keep myself active
mm-hmm Roy Roy Dean actually Roy heard
the how I speak my earlier Roy Dean is
one of his black boxes she was just at
his house this weekend in na in Palm
Desert and he said something to me or
I'd even said to me I was in one of his
books called beyond the black belt and
it always stuck with me cuz it changed
my life actually cuz you know I was
always the guy who I thought that you
know anything you wanted to be good at
let's say was jiu-jitsu business or
relationships or whatever it was that
you could go read the book
do the work do the practice and you
could earn that ability and then you've
got and you can check the box okay I'm a
Jitsu guy on my comedy guy oh my great
love or whatever it is right but it
doesn't work like that I realized that
what Roy Dean said is as a man you're
always paying your dues always that
never stops never stop and never son
that that it was difficult for me to
accept that because I thought it was I
thought it was a finish line right like
one day I'll have my [ __ ] figured out
and I can chill out but it doesn't work
like that yeah that's scary you know a
lot of people a lot of young kids listen
to the show young men mm-hm and I love
that they listen to the show because I
want them to know what they get wouldn't
nobody tells you mmm you know the [ __ ]
you gotta figure out along the way this
is what this show is for these guys I
could look you in the [ __ ] eye and
tell you two things number one if you
fell it boëthius thought at the age of
21 I'd be working as hard as I'm working
now you're [ __ ] out of your mind and
number two if I didn't even think I'd be
[ __ ] alive right now
never mind working I'm working hard at
today guys than what I did at 25 no I
put more I was in a week now than what I
do at 25 and don't tell me about going
on a road that's a complete different
set of [ __ ] hours I never thought I'd
work this hard like I never thought this
is mentally you know because there's a
lot of mental involved you do a lot of
writing it's a lot of mental involved a
lot of notebooks a lot of pages the
writing alone is 2 hours a day and you
really some days don't get nothing
hellos - when I was your really belt
you're just making joint you know unless
you're right in like a book that's ready
to go sometimes I'm trying to write a
book and [ __ ] write a comedy routine
at the same time because while I'm
writing the book at least I'm not doing
there it's not that there I'm not
wasting my time and sometimes I'll go
back to that joke though oh maybe I'll
attack her from this way and that's what
also jujitsu is done it's opened up my
thinking out of those it opens up your
thinking patterns and now you write
different types of jokes you know
because and jujitsu you can't go
full-speed all
for me at my age that have a role a
restaurant made a troll restroom it I
try to do the same thing on stage mm-hmm
I learned half in jiu-jitsu and you find
like when you take that rest that kind
of on stage it kind of builds tension in
the audience yes that makes the jokes
right better yes absolutely sting all
those things have jiu-jitsu has opened
up my eyes that it's made my way better
comedian it's [ __ ] crazy it's crazy
you said to me earlier why do you think
did you see quote you so so hard like
and I I mean I have an answer it might
not be the right one but I have one you
know sitting with my friend Jake who
runs Budo videos calm which is a big
martial arts he's you know him but Oh
Jake you've seen a boy yeah he
interviews a lot jiu-jitsu guys very
cool dude and and his new thing is acro
yoga you know acro yoga what you do with
a partner so basically you lie on your
back and then your partner will do like
a handstand off your hands or something
like that so one guy supporting and then
the other person is being like held up
and they're balancing and he was
teaching me some of this stuff and we
were out in the park doing it and I said
to him and this is this is far from a
bad lifestyle day as possible but we're
on the other end of the spectrum like
the crappiest thing we could be doing
today is sitting under some fluorescent
lights hunched over a computer eating
some bad food you know like doing
something we don't enjoy and we're on
the other side of that spectrum and I
think jiu-jitsu is also there like when
you go to a gym okay you're doing
physical activity right it's using your
body it's using your mind but you're
also connecting with people you're
talking people like you're you it's
camaraderie right it's fellowship
something that a lot of people don't get
and it's I think these are things that
people crave man people crave human
contact they crave stimulation
intellectual stimulation physical
stimulation and maybe you just got those
things in a way that you weren't getting
before I don't know I guess I know for a
fact that
when I look at my daily schedule if I
see a lot of holes in that schedule I
will definitely go to jiu-jitsu he'll
make me go to jiu-jitsu more even though
I was gonna go anyway
hmm it would make me go more so I get
human contact so I feel like a regular
person
you know exams yeah cuz I mean IIIi
don't know about you but I spend a lot
of time working from home alone and
either working from a coffee shop and
after if like a few hours yeah you start
feeling you get like cabin fever and you
start feeling strange like a like The
Walking Dead basically and then when you
connect but then you go to jiu-jitsu
class and even you connect you see like
ten or twenty or thirty people and you
work and you sweat and like your body's
moving when when you leave that class I
feel human again
you know does that make sense I usually
my old schedule was leave the house at
8:00 called a coffee shop eat breakfast
make a few calls right and then at ten
is ten fifteen go home first off for
your back you can't sit there oh yes so
bad so I give myself two hours now
that's all that's all your backs got to
sin that's all you got to sit so 8:30 to
10:30 I get up I go home I do some other
work on my computer maybe help my wife
was [ __ ] she answers and then I start
putting my gear you know and I go over
there and it's like I said twelve to one
fifteen give another let's go couple
jump in there woman boom get the [ __ ]
out of there you go home you take a
shower you right now the first thing I
do is log in my calendar I trained what
I learned
let's go and how many times I rolled and
how I did and what I got out of the
class
you know what today I got [ __ ] tapped
18 times but I'll tell you what did
happen I [ __ ] retained my guard from
professor one time so I don't focus on
the negative I focus on that one
positive itit means I'm gonna get choked
out every day if I go but I read then do
something else I'd crawl underneath I
bump a guy off that's an amount over me
I'd do something so I take that one one
thing like usually as a positive and
it's cool and instead of killing myself
and going to class and judging myself
against what everybody else is doing I
got a plan
I'm learning the technique I'm rolling
five three times and I'm going home no
matter how I feel I will do the
commitment of three times like the walk
again tomorrow and come back on [ __ ]
Thursday yeah yeah it's like I think the
gym is the same or any any like thing
that challenges you often man often
there tons I've got a jiu-jitsu class
that evening or in the morning or
there's a workout on that at lunchtime
whatever and I don't want to do it man I
don't [ __ ] want to do it but there's
one thing that always happens when I do
it and that is afterwards I'm glad I did
it every single time no matter how much
I didn't want to do it guarantee that
come out of that workout I'm like yeah I
feel better I did the same thing
Saturday yeah went to him who I was in
Columbus Thursday I flew and it was the
red-eye I slept all day had worked out
three days in a row anyway needed to
recovery day anyway so I used to as they
Friday with the who hopes gym short
North Muay Thai and sadly I usually
since I'm gonna leave early and took a
bat but I woke up at like 2:00 feeling
kind of shitty and what I got a pro
breakfast a breakfast without smoke to
join walked around for a half hour just
to burn off the breakfast and I went
upstairs and I fell asleep to about 1:30
I had a piece of fish and I went back to
the room and I was like now right and
finally if they were gonna pick me up at
6:45 then five I said [ __ ] this I'm
going to the gym and I ran downstairs of
the 20 on eucalyptus whatever the
elliptical twenty five minutes you lift
like that every body part uh-huh I did
sit-ups with eight to twelve pound ball
this is gym in your house and hotel oh
no it's okay I'm training like one thing
listen like I said we all have our own
personal jeet kune do-- Joe Rogan is a
winner and you know why because since
I've known him he works out on the road
before the shows interesting ever since
I've known Joe I remember him making me
go to the gym with my Joey you have to
go to the gym with the Desai's he and he
would be [ __ ] jumping up and down
like
with a dumbbell in the corner because at
least you camp you didn't sit in your
room and you got to thinking I never
really thought about and then when I
would go on the road by myself I'd walk
past a gym and give it the finger yeah
[ __ ] you yeah
and now the gym is imperative all he
wrote both days yeah you know the
there's a it's like a a common element
amongst all people who are actualized
and already making their way and making
their mark in the world and that is that
they exercise some connects it might be
jujitsu it might be yoga it might be
shooting hoops a couple of times a week
but like your body's made to move it's
made to exercise in a few if you violate
that you're gonna pay the price in some
way or another whether it's your minds
gonna get stale or you're gonna get sick
or you're gonna get fat it's gonna
happen I got really sick I think of the
sleep app here the fat roll up on me and
maybe the fact Auld up on me and 20
pound increments you know one minute I'd
be 360 and I'd be 380 one minute i'm 380
the next when i'm 400 man i don't forget
when i found that i was four sixteen but
I felt like that day when I got home
yeah and then like a week later I did a
commercial had a with Pacquiao trans
okay pretty right Freddie wrote for
another commercial with tonight and the
guy that letter said was one of
Freddie's trainers and we got to talking
English you know I saw you know longest
shot and while I'm watching you I can
tell you can't [ __ ] breathe so don't
you want to take Canon and what you want
to live and I was like what the [ __ ] he
was Boston and he goes come to the gym
every dang give me 20 hours not training
you for an hour and I would have to wear
two pair along the way because I would
pee my pants while he was training me I
couldn't breathe like you're imaginary
yeah and then left a 370 mark I finally
gave in and went to Weight Watchers
uh-huh and what are you woody Wayne on
joy
283 yeah I mean not many people these
140 pounds I gotta do another I got to
go down to 265 so I can fight steep in
the old chick just in case
oh man I'm gonna run to 265 is oh my god
there's no reason why I should wait 200
more than 65 gonna at 265 I'll see who I
am but I will tell you this when I
started going over and training with
Bret the second day he said something to
me that struck a chord hmm I said
something goes you know what's crazy
I could feel weight on me now that I've
been doing jujitsu for 20 years you feel
weight on you by the by the way you're
oh my god what do you mean he goes I
could tell when I go home and eat with
my family I can feel the 10 pounds in my
row it's a big difference yeah I'm sad a
son he's 20 whatever pounds I lost big
difference yeah Roland and it's
something gonna get better Yeaton the
next 20 he's gonna be better on there my
god now I could roll like I said yeah
three five with it legit rounds from I
can't Baron bolo I don't want you to
throw me I want to throw you
professional they'll throw you forwards
till you see the bottom and lay that low
you give some shoutouts real quick Ian
let's see what the [ __ ] is
crack-a-lackin'
my girl Lisa Tazio of my friend the 50
[ __ ] years happy birthday Billy
Farley Cowell Wallace Joe seseri uncle
Donnie my [ __ ] main man down in Miami
Lorenzo Toledo
Megan O'Brien Mike ax 2 to 7 John our
star and unique net you know I love your
[ __ ] don't forget next weekend
we're at the Tempe [ __ ] improv
Thursday Friday and Saturday then I'm in
Providence Rhode Island on the 17 we
just sold out so don't even bother and
then we're at the [ __ ] stressed
Factory the 18th and 19th in new new new
jersey and [ __ ] but besides that so you
just want something that is [ __ ]
revolutionary I got a good chance to
look at it on the plane because I
downloaded it to my laptop like the
little [ __ ] what's up what am i wife
by me
an iPad the iPad because I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm doing somehow I've got
me an iPad I went on your uh the master
has been a cat Oh [ __ ] tremendous I'm
so happy
ok what was really interesting about the
the the critique the rolling analysis
rolling in the ass a lot how long did
you come up with this concept for bomb
that's why I called you the guy who's
there if that there's a lot of
well-known names in jujitsu but in my
book you are the true kung fu
jujin nice so world you have a great
smile a great voice you're very soothing
you really spread the love side of
jiu-jitsu monster if you don't
understand I mean the thing the other
thing I downloaded you the book you sent
me and that was beyond the black that
was great that was great the one that
you give me a shot of yeah there's a
thousand scams on the internet yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got which they really
are yeah no because you talked about
friends of yours at you know stuff like
that but tell me more about this master
online academy like tell people uh break
it down like one of the true advantages
I mean I thought with the analysis
that's what I really liked you know I
always loved your technique
you always want for no exercise I mean
you're like a [ __ ] need to spread
Bajada I appreciate you're a man you
know like look I've never I've taught at
a few Jiu Jitsu academies but I've never
owned my own Academy and that's
generally the path like for someone who
makes you Jitsu their career is they
either become an MMA fighter or they own
a gym or they do both right that's the
the path but for me I'm the kind of
person I don't want to do anything like
half-measures I've always been if I'm
gonna do something I want to give it my
full focus and attention and when I
arrived here in the United States I was
considering opening a gym but something
was holding me back because uh you know
I travel a lot I go to teach seminars in
different parts of the world and if you
travel a lot you can't focus on an
academy because you can't you're not
there all the time and I just had the
feeling I would I would wouldn't be able
to give that Academy as much attention
as as I as I should you know and have
these students who I'd see for a week
and then I'd be away for two weeks and
then I come back
see them again and never be able to give
like full commitment so what I thought
is like you know the best way around
this is to have an online Academy
because then I can put my full focus and
it's open all the time and I can do it
from the road and I can film and add
stuff to it all the time and yeah that's
what I've done and I I just try to pour
everything of my understanding of
jiu-jitsu in the way I approach my
jujitsu training and the way I teach
into that and I guess it's the best way
I can describe it which you're just
phenomenal thank you so much you you
know you tape some seminars and I
watched little things that you do and
it's weird because I watched other
videos and there's a lot of information
on here to know about jujitsu you can
become a [ __ ] black belt now online
with a little dummy next eatables and
[ __ ] like what real little dummy is what
I'm saying but you teach the little
things the same reason when I first
started the first year I would look at
your little whatever I would learn a
move in class I would look to see if you
taught it as I would learn to see the
techniques that they left out you know
it's in jujitsu and the first two were
two academies I went to it was that
gonna tallien love it giving your recipe
they always leave something up for you
to figure out on your own
you know was ailing and then what you
figure that you like that's what you
Jitsu is Jiu Jitsu is an art like
stand-up comedy because neither bees
will do long bar the same way Lee does
the stolid jokes and I do a style of
jokes it's our world your jujitsu I said
to you I have a plan now it's either a
college choke a scissor sweep one arm
bar and once that plan gets a board it
starts all over again and that plan also
throws you off because I'm always
attacking off my back I'm always
attacking him I'm always attacking it's
tough for you to pass if I'm constantly
attacking I'm breathing I'm focused I
got my neck up off this again I'm
sailing I'm doing all these things if I
thank you Jitsu just for the breathing
aspect of what's happened I got so
serious about I got the bas Rutten
mouthpiece no [ __ ]
I never tried that and I got the bow
through mouthpiece and I did it and I
said [ __ ] this this works so I said let
me take this and let me do let me eat
that it's something different
I went on YouTube and saw a black dude
throwing sidekicks for Jesus with the
mouthpiece I I said [ __ ] this I'm gonna
take the mouthpiece and start golfer
walks oh my god first half-hour you feel
like you're gonna pass out
yeah there's first two minutes you're
like I'm gonna go down and even it's
like somebody's choking me a little by
little but I kept saying it myself
breathe it out Joey breathe it out
breathe it out I started doing that and
that alone I mean when you do that [ __ ]
for a half-hour you just bring the
mouthpiece almost I give you a thousand
setups [ __ ] I mean I really put work
into my jujitsu game but it's not my
jujitsu game I've put work into my game
like my own life game I represent it
hasn't been for jujitsu that's why I'm
saying I benefited so much from walking
into that Academy yeah but you know like
one of the things I'm very fond of
discussing with people is okay jujitsu
look it's it's grappling right it's it's
trying to strangle the other guy right
but you know how they're these better
ways of strangling people and there's
better ways of doing arm rods and
there's better ways of doing sweeps and
that's what jujitsu is is it's trying to
find those best most efficient ways and
I think that life is so much like that
and you in everything in life there are
better
the average ways and there's better ways
of doing it whatever whether it's
talking to someone or doing a business
deal or eating a meal whatever it is
there's better ways to do things and I'm
always looking for those better ways not
just in jujitsu but in everything in
everything I do and I think that's like
a that's a healthy mindset to have but
like life is jiu-jitsu you know you do
you're trying to jiu-jitsu life right
you're trying to do it as best you can
but at least that's my theory right it's
like I said before we all have a G chord
oh that works for you mm-hmm Jake will
do my cheek window a little bit he's
been taken from you a little bit has
been taken from Rogan I learned a lot
from Ralphie May as a comic and then I
learned from Richard Pryor's mistakes
you know I've learned from Tennyson's
mistakes I've learned through dices
mistakes just being a spectator to them
you know how I'm supposed to act and
family and stuff like that
and you pull it all together and it
comes up with a recipe and that's who
you are
you know as well I could admit this to
anybody I'm just 10 people rolled up
into one
mm-hmm people that I got to meet that I
thought they did something that was
successful and I was in a state take
that element from their lives
and that's what I do you know I look at
podcasts will the best podcasters I see
what they do and I do exactly what
they're doing only with my flavor that's
the G kundo you know I'm still doing
this podcast so I want to do it observe
what was was firstly saying absorb what
is useful reject what is this absolutely
absolutely
yeah why are you looking at what number
30 is doing look at what number one is
doing yeah and don't steal his move
steal what he's thinking mm-hmm steal
the concept of what he's thinking to
make him that good it's not that he
practices felony it's definitely
stronger than you have to be younger
than you he did something to get there
watch what he's doing and that'll get
you there add your flavor what you bring
to the table and together you'll get
there to whatever point you think
successes whatever your successes you
know and always give credit as well
oh yeah oh man I've emulated from dr. J
you know my style of comedy is dr. Jam
taking it to the [ __ ] hope Jack ain't
got time to dig around and tell your
[ __ ] fickle story let's go [ __ ]
you know so dr. J's you know let it's
get it you know like Joey what the [ __ ]
does let it's gonna teach you but it's
gonna teach us me to go out there and
overpower the audience with my whatever
I'm thinking without your [ __ ] were you
thinking dog is what I'm thinking for
you to win an audience over that's your
attitude
once you it's like the amount we would
do it open mike lee and i and some great
little kid run up on stage and he asked
if this word was offensive I thought
that was the biggest mistake atomic
could ever do are you ought to say which
word that was uh Joe might say yeah he
said is is the gay man's anus offends
anyone's I think it was just I think
that was a joke it was a joke it was a
joke
but he still asked you never asked
you'll never ask permission to do you
are yeah
it's your art yeah that's a funny enough
it's it's reminds me of another saying I
think it's from that book by Tim Ferriss
the guy wrote the 4-hour workweek and he
said I hope I get this right he said you
asked permission later act first and ask
permission after me yeah yeah which i
think is cool a lot of people we're
trained as like in Western society like
in school you're trained to like follow
the rules and not like deviate from the
path right but the people who make it
the furthest then you live the most
exciting lives they don't necessarily
break the rules but they definitely bend
them you bendin yeah you have to blend
them a little bit yeah
I didn't like well I can't you know that
was a young man I didn't I bought it I
bought it for a while I bought the white
fence with the house and marrying a high
school sweetheart and doing all that
[ __ ] and you see the American Dream is
an American grave the American Dream is
truly an American grave and if the
American Dream is buying a house and
working 50 hours a week till you die you
get a gold watch when you're 65
hopefully that's a dead drain there I
think the American Dream is coming here
and giving yourself no limitations you
know I told Lidia there somebody was on
the show well they became a car salesman
it was the best thing I ever did because
it taught me that you don't need to have
a ceiling on your income you know
what'll go for it [ __ ] go for it
someone should make 2,000 some months
you make eight hundred but there's some
months you're gonna make that down yeah
you're not gonna know until you try you
could keep sitting this [ __ ] job or
you'd go for it and life generally
desert as a saying I love which is
nature loves courage right yeah nature
loves courage like in that you know you
know I've seen that with the people who
everyone's story is the same everyone
who makes it their story is the same
there was a point where there was no one
helping them and it came the situation
was dire and it came down to them they
had to take courageous action no
do it for them and you can't fake it you
know they had to [ __ ] make that leap
whether it's move somewhere or take some
job they were terrified of or they had
to do that on their own and I find that
fascinating yeah you know it's so weird
how people think you could just page on
Jacques Machado four hundred an hour
I'll do that ten weeks now become a
jujitsu master they don't see the true
essence of it is that going it's going
to a class one or a couple classes a
week I think the new society expects
gratification too quickly you know I
didn't even see and he can form up
calmly success really for seven years
you know what it is to do something for
seven or eight years to see nothing no
lady just the [ __ ] ham and Egger yeah
it wasn't so Mitzi shore rested soul
made me a regular that I can go well
maybe there is something to this it's
like becoming a purple belt in jujitsu
when you don't aren't really a purple
belt you know and then you become a
purple belt yeah like when I got into
the Comedy Store I wasn't a good
comedian but it forced me to become a
good comedian quickly because if not I
was gonna go away and not get another
shot so I had to go back to basics one
of the basics closed guard yeah
armbar and says his food is listening to
an interesting um audiobook yesterday
and this guy was telling the story of
this this guy who ran his business away
I had I had a business and it wasn't
doing well and he hated it and he said
every day you'd get to his offices and
he had said himself I just have to open
the door I just have to put the key in
the door and open it that's all I have
to do today and eventually like the
business turned around and he became a
successful guy but he says he sometimes
reminisce is on that and realizes how
how many times he came so close to just
not opening that door and is saying I'm
done they just so happy pushed through
and [ __ ] mine everyone who makes it that
stays like that everyone every single
person who's made it I'm sure as many
days where they're like I just I don't
want to do this anymore I want to give
up right it's not worth it or it's not
working and it's having that like
courage to push through I think which is
really important I don't know I went to
my knee doctor
when I was in jujitsu like a year and
that was a really struggling I didn't
know what was going on I would just go
to judicial to die basically I went to
the knee doc that he goes listen quit
that [ __ ] he goes for some reason I mean
getting people coming in here with
broken [ __ ] ankles this [ __ ]
jujitsu [ __ ] LS [ __ ] two years
earlier Trey why do [ __ ] people do
that type of [ __ ] quit that [ __ ] and
imma driving home going he's right
who the [ __ ] am I to think but I can do
that type of stuff I'm [ __ ] quitting
I'm like I'm driving I'm gonna [ __ ] him
yeah [ __ ] Gwen no house this week I'm
indeed um at your guy tomorrow and
sub-conscience over on Lankershim in
North Hollywood great place 7:30 start
indeed so what's the name of the call
you you this seminar to efficiency
beyond technique beyond techniques I'm
not okay and where are you sadly you
somewhat Phoenix black flag digits here
okay and that you Lou home Tucson is
Manuel Tucson yeah that's what my kid
nappy is yeah that's the kidnap be this
is instead of the chair he's coming to
the show on Tempe he's coming Friday
night which is going to be interesting
yeah if Captain valo shows up to Tempe
on Friday night people you're there I'm
gonna put him on stage and Tom to say
his side of the story his perspective of
getting kidnapped and the whole [ __ ]
deal it's kind of crazy but it happened
and I can't change around my wife you're
not gonna come to your show on Saturday
in Tempe is I will leave you tickets at
the door
professor I'm happy to see you me as
well thank you for doing what you do
think about like you know I don't know
what it costs for the marking when you
do or whatever it is a month whatever it
is it's mortem worth it why cuz this guy
loves jiu-jitsu like I said he is the
true kung fu' of jiu-jitsu and I love
you to death
thanks so much killing your video thanks
Emmy thank you for all the content thank
you for the emails I mean you really
stay on it and sometimes you you like I
don't want to go did you just play and
also you look at your emails illicit
email from you talking about a friend of
yours
plus you have a great podcast you know
this week you have the guy on oh he's
great he's [ __ ] great
yeah yeah yeah I haven't listened to it
yet but I heard his name before you have
a great podcast I mean you dedicate your
life to this and I was thinking about
you and I want you to tell people the
truth when you commit to what you love
does the universe not take a did uh when
you go to Tyler he told me I started
once about time in the Sun I'm right
here tell his mother [ __ ] universe
doesn't take the area that guy who
hosted um the guy who hosted that the
Miss World and he kind of got it wrong I
forget his name
Steve Harvey Steve Harvey like he he's
got an interesting clip on YouTube and
he said it's like you've got this
parachute on your back right which is
the universal support but the only way
you're gonna know if that parachute
works is if you jump out the plane it's
if you take that courageous step but
it's the only way to tell and you have
to do that there's no one else who can
do it for you so I would say yes the
universe does step up to support you if
somebody wants to join up for the master
online will they do I just head on over
do too just did you to master
academy.com
and everything is there I'll answer yeah
if they use um coupon code podcast they
can get 10% off only where my jujitsu
Brotherhood oh yeah yeah rascal when we
said that to you who's a white belt one
and then you got your blue by the time
it arrived yet your blue belt so you
gotta say you know I don't care I'm just
happy that I still represent it I'm
happy you made time for us I'm looking
forward to the seminar tomorrow night
7:30 over here and no home at
subconscient BJJ give him a call right
now I'm sure they're there make
reservations it's a big place but it's a
small place you know you know so make
your reservations and get your [ __ ]
together
thank you again professor thanks so much
again Jewish lightning you know I love
you [ __ ] everything all right in
your world
everything's be let's get over this
[ __ ] [ __ ] bronchitis you got in this
[ __ ] again if you're looking for a great
guy Fuji sports calm I love Fuji if
you're a big guy they got you covered
you know I went from an eight-six to an
85 now I got I got on an a4 and then
hopefully an 83 but they're tough why
because I was always on top and I'd be
pulled on yanked on [ __ ] tried to
harm drag and guess what [ __ ] they
could never rip the gate that's why I
believe in the super rod Oggy so
go to Fuji sports.com right now I'm
pressing Church BAM you get 10% off the
Liberty house but she's a point in the
podcast also to my favorite supplement
company out there who takes care of me
always audit calm if it's not the shroom
tech sport it's a shroom tech immune I
fly a lot the immune you don't see me
[ __ ] coughing and the shroom tech
sport I take a half a [ __ ] little
capsule excuse me and I'm jumping up and
down like a Mexican [ __ ] beans you're
saying so gonna calm right now press in
church another one get 10% off delivered
right to your house I want to thank
professor Nick Gregory Alice and my main
[ __ ] Lisa I am and I want to
thank you guys for listening
I'll see you [ __ ] nice and
early Monday morning don't forget
[ __ ] tip tapi Arizona sink us demise
the Cuban in Mexican Ville throwing it
down I love you [ __ ] stay black
have a great weekend and I'll see you
guys next week
love you [ __ ]